DAN GALPIN: Android 8.1
Oreo contains a targeted set
of enhancements, including
optimizations for Android Go
and a new Neural Networks API.
We've also included a
few smaller enhancements
in response to user
and developer feedback.
Android 8.1 includes memory
optimizations for Android Go--
hardware that has one
gigabyte or less of RAM.
For example, Notification
Listener Service
and Condition Provider
Service will not
be supported on low RAM devices.
In addition, we've added new
hardware feature constants
so you can now target the
distribution of your apps
and APK splits to normal
or low RAM devices
if they're running
Android 8.1 and later.
We've been working hard to bring
on-device machine intelligence
to mobile with features such
as Now Playing and Google Lens.
The new Neural Networks
API lays the foundation
for our developer
community to build
accelerated on-device
applications
of machine learning,
including image recognition
and prediction.
The Neural Networks
API runtime is
designed to efficiently
distribute the computation
workload across available
on-device processors,
including dedicated neural
network hardware, graphics
processing units, and
digital signal processors.
For devices that lack
a specialized vendor
driver or hardware, the runtime
relies on optimized code
to execute requests on the CPU.
It's unlikely that most apps
will use the Neural Networks
API directly.
They'll instead rely
on a higher level
machine learning framework such
as TensorFlow Lite or Caffe 2.
TensorFlow Lite is Google's
cross-platform open source
framework designed to
execute deep trained neural
networks in mobile
environments, and it's
scheduled to be released soon,
so make sure to stay tuned.
We also are investing bringing
the benefits of deep learning
to more developers, so we
intend to release a library
to make common ML use
cases easily available
on mobile devices.
Android 8.1 Oreo adds a
new Shared Memory API.
This new API
enables the creation
of an anonymous shared
memory instance.
You can mmap the shared memory
object into a local byte buffer
and read and write it like
any other byte buffer.
The memory protection
can be controlled
on the shared object.
Since the shared memory
object is parcelable,
you can easily pass it to
another process through AIDL.
The remote process
can then map any part
of the memory it wants, and
once access is no longer needed,
just unmap the buffer.
The Shared Memory API also
supports interoperability
with the NDK using
a shared memory.
We can mmap the FD and
then read and write.
It's a great way to share data
between multiple processes,
within a single app,
or even between apps.
We've added some polish
and refinement to Autofill.
Most of the changes are on
the Autofill service side.
For example, the Save UI now
supports custom descriptions,
so when asking to
save credit card data,
the service can request a
displayable logo representing
the type of credit card, the
last four digits of the card
number, and an expiration date.
This helps the user understand
exactly what is being saved.
One minor change for apps
that want to support Autofill
is that base adapter
and its derived classes,
such as Array
Adapter, now support
setting Autofill options.
This makes it easier to provide
Autofill data for simple custom
adapters, such as one used
to set credit card expiration
dates.
In Android 8.0, you would need
to override the Get Autofill
method options in the adapter,
but now in 8.1, you can just
call Set Autofill options.
And in another helpful
touch, the API 27 version
of the support
library view compat
now wraps the Autofill
methods to make it easier
to give hints to the Autofill
service, which you really
should do.
One more Autofill note--
consider setting up an
association between your app
and your website.
This allows the Autofill
service to share passwords
between the two, whether you
run Android 8.0 or Android 8.1.
Android 8.1 includes the new
APIs in the Wallpaper Manager
to get the most
representative colors
from the current wallpaper.
And the system UI
and Pixel launcher
will adjust the colors they
use based upon this API.
If you've made a
live wallpaper, you
notify the wallpaper
service whenever your colors
change significantly, returning
them in the On Compute Colors
method.
We recommend using the utility
functions within the Wallpaper
Colors class to
automatically select
these colors from a
representative bitmap
or drawable.
Some other changes you
might be interested in--
Edit Text now returns
an editable rather than
a care sequence.
Your app can determine
how it responds
to a known threat from the Web
View implementation of the Safe
Browsing API.
The Media Metadata
Retriever class
has a new method, Get
Scaled Frame At Time,
that finds a frame near
a given time position
and returns a bitmap with the
same aspect ratio as the source
frame, but at the
requested size.
If you have any Pixel
or Pixel 2 device,
we support requesting
A-audio sharing
mode exclusive in
some cases, which
provides reduced audio latency.
Better yet, we've
released a preview
of the Oboe library, which
allows applications to target
A-Audio on API 26 plus
devices and Open SL
on previous versions of
Android to get the best
latency with a simplified API
surface in a compatible way.
If you have a Pixel 2, you'll
notice a developer setting
in Android 8.1 for
Camera HAL HDR+.
This enables you to test an
early version of HDR+ with
Pixel Visual Core, Google's
first custom designed
co-processor for
consumer products.
Note that HDR+ will only be
enabled for specific Camera
and Camera2 API options.
If you have an eligible
Pixel or Nexus device,
you can enroll it in Android
Beta to get the latest update,
but we also have Android
8.1 emulator images.
This gives you the
opportunity to fix any issues
and update your app
before consumers
get their hands on 8.1.
You can find out more about
everything we covered,
including the developer
preview program here.
Happy coding.
[MUSIC PLAYING]